thank you kendall the holidays and
celebrating the new year are usually
times of great joy right but they can
also be times of great depression
especially right now
i spoke with the southwest medical
doctor to learn more
hey dr goku welcome back thank you so
much great to be with you
as always you know we're giving people
some information about
how to take care of themselves
especially during the holidays when
depression
is at a higher rate right that's right
you know it's a very festive and fun
holiday season
but at the same time it can be a very
challenging time for people who are
dealing with difficult illnesses or with
the loss of loved ones
right especially now um so what are the
signs that people should look out for
in themselves or others sure recognizing
depression
in yourself or in others starts with
knowing some of the important signs and
symptoms
expressions of helplessness feelings of
worthlessness or sadness
lack of attention to personal care and
hygiene
increased use of substances such as
alcohol or other drugs
irresponsible behavior loss of interest
in daily activities
obsessive thoughts about death and
suicide and even weight loss or loss of
appetite are important signs to look out
for
oh so sad and what can family members or
caregivers do
to help these people when they see these
signs
family members and caregivers can have a
huge impact on patients that are
struggling with this
take time to listen patients who
actually feel like they're being heard
can really make a difference
in their lives also recognizing that
they need time
to rest and recharge in between family
visits and activities is important
and if you can't visit make a phone call
it's also important to remember that
just as these patients do the caregivers
also need that time as well so make sure
you're taking good care of yourself also
good advice something to remember for
people taking care of others but
especially during this time during the
pandemic you know we're worried about
our
physical health but mental health is has
to be a priority right
absolutely go hand in hand and it's
important to pay attention to all of
these signs
all right dr gokul thank you so much as
always it's a pleasure stay safe
we want to thank southwest medical for
being a community pride partner las
vegas now will be right